qu'elle a été brûlée à l'acide les
paupières ont été scalpées donc des yeux
très abîmés je pense que vous pouvez à
peu près à le voir elle devait avoir
très soif elle était en train de de
lécher une petite flaque d'eau de pluie
elle est à bout de force bien sûr je
suis désolé mais complètement dépourvu
d'humanité pour considérer le chat comme
un objet qu'on peut brûler qu'on peut
acheter à la poubelle donc il faut
sanctionner ces mecs là qui sont pardon
mais des merdes et j'espère qu'il vous
diront en prison et moi quand ma mère la
récupérer elle est montée dans la
voiture elle était remplie d'amour
c'est incroyable la confiance qu'elle a
encore donné à l'être humain elle était
collée à ma maman s'est senti sauvage à
l'être humain
et beau